bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qui représente un véritable
vaccin contre les bêtises économique
bien plus grave
kolko vide
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses caches la sphère était censé être
pliée en juillet dernier après de
longues négociations les 27 pays de
l'union européenne avaient fini par
accorder leurs violons sur le plan de
relance destiné à soutenir les économies
à des pays européens mise à mal par la
crise sanitaire
c'était sans compter sur la hongrie qui
est venu chambouler les plans de
bruxelles suivis à part la pologne et la
slovénie pourquoi le pays at il mis son
veto sur ce plan de relance après la
crise sanitaire va-t-on assister à une
crise diplomatique
comment lieu peut-elle sortir de cette
impasse on va en parler dans cette
émission avec vous olivier et puis en
deuxième partie nous serons avec à
sylvie matelly économistes et directrice
adjointe de l'iris l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques
que s'est il passé entre juillet dernier
la mi novembre pour que la hongrie puis
la pologne tous deux soutenus par la
slovénie des sites d'apposer leur veto
au plan de relance de l'union européenne
éléments de réponse avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine d'assas
sur le papier il était bien ficelé ce
plan de relance européen 750 milliards
d'euros pour lutter contre la crise
provoquée par l'ico vide une sacrée
somme à la hauteur des dommages causés
une union européenne forte qui répond
présent face à ce qui est sans doute
l'un des plus grands défis de son
histoire récente
sauf que bah ça a coincé et en hongrie
et la pologne ont posé leur veto
soutenue ensuite par la slovénie et ont
donc enrayer toute la pelle machine
européenne qui après une crise sanitaire
une crise financière gut maintenant à la
crise diplomatique
miam en fait les pays s'opposent à une
petite clause en bas du contrat tout
petit le respect obligatoire de l'état
de droit
question que me direz vous eh bien on
sait pas trop mais en fait sur le papier
ce serait des règles qui pourraient
sembler basique comme un processus
d'adoption des lois transparent des
tribunaux indépendants et impartiaux la
séparation des pouvoirs où la liberté de
la presse
c'est un manquement à l'état de droit
est observé par le conseil de l'union
européenne formée par les états membres
l'attribution des fonds européens
pourraient être suspendus
la pologne et surtout la hongrie qui ont
notamment des politiques plus ferme sur
l'immigration par exemple craignent donc
de se retrouver et puniques qu'on leur
retire les fonds européens ou qu'ils
perdent leur souveraineté et leur
liberté d'agir comme ils le souhaitent
dans leur pays du côté europe
que ce principe est avant tout là pour
contrôler l'utilisation de ces fonds
financé par le contribuable européen lui
a en tout cas déjà annoncé qu'il allait
essayer de contourner ces veto et ainsi
pouvoir se passer de l'accord de la
pologne et de la hongrie
olivier après la crise sanitaire la
crise économique voici venu le temps de
la crise diplomatique
c'est sympa ce petit club l'a présenté
par ares l'europe ou en effet comme dans
les contrats d'assurance ou ça et on met
en dernière ligne en tout petit une
petite clause qui permet soit de de
priver de souveraineté ces pays-là soin
de leurs de leurs données privées
dessous donc évidemment que ces pays là
rue dans les brancards il y avait qu'à
pas mettre cette phrase d'autant plus
que si vous voulez c'est c'est donc
l'europe qui va le petit club qui va
juger de ce que l'état de droit est
respecté dans ces pays là ou pas mais
l'état de droit est il respecté en
france par exemple
donc on peut se poser la question donc
moi je je je trouve que ils ont raison
de le faire et en plus je vais vous dire
je suis ravi qu'il le fasse pour la
bonne et simple raison que je vous
rappelle que ce plan de relance était
une aberration c'est à dire que nous
payons 100 milliards pour en récupérer
que je sache ça fait toujours moins 60
donc ça n'est pas dans le san et ça
n'aide pas à la france et il s'est en
aucun cas un bon calcul pour nous donc
que les hongrois et les polonais
continue
nous n'en seront que mieux merci olivier
on passe tout de suite à la deuxième
partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec sylvie matelly bonjour vous êtes
économiste directrice adjointe de l'iris
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques bienvenue financer cash
bonjour sylvie matelly on l'a vu un
totalement dans la première partie dans
le tiroir cache la hongrie et la pologne
souhaite l'abandon d'un nouveau
mécanisme qui conditionne donc le
versement des fonds au respect de l'état
de droit
en résumé budapest craint d'être
sanctionnée pour sa politique
anti-immigration et varsovie et moi je
cite un combat idéologique contre ces
valeurs de l'autre côté on a aussi la
van der leyen qui a qualifié à ces deux
vétos d'irresponsable et qui a dénoncé
les mensonges de la hongrie alors
concrètement à sylvie matelly
ce mécanisme permet t-il oui ou non a
lieu de s'ingérer sur des questions de
société ou de santé par exemple
en d'autres termes est ce qui menace la
souveraineté de ces pays non on peut pas
on peut pas dire ça parce que c'est
nettement exagéré d'abord il s'agit d'un
plan de relance donc c'est un plan de
750 milliards d'euros dont une bonne
partie est destinée et va financer la
relance en hongrie et en pologne aussi
la hongrie la pologne faut le rappeler
sont parmi les principaux bénéficiaires
de ce plan donc avant de verser ce cd
montant important à ces pays
rappelons le qui constitue quand même de
l'argent payé par des contribuables
européens et pas seulement polonais
hongrois
les européens ont décidé de mettre en
place ce qu'on appelle une une clause de
conditionnalité c'est à dire ils
conditionnent ce versement au respect de
certaines mesures de l'état de droit
alors évidemment si vous regardez ça
juste comme ça vous dit ah bah ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que ils vont
seule l'europe va s'ingérer dans le fait
qu'on autorise toujours pas l'avortement
ou va nous obliger à accueillir des
migrants
en réalité c'est pas du tout ça les
textes sont assez précis il est dit dans
les textes
excusez moi et sur cette conditionnalité
qu'en réalité
l'europe veut pouvoir contrôler la bonne
affectation la bonne à nos allocations
de ces fonds et le fait que
ces fonds vont véritablement relancer la
croissance économique dans ces pays donc
vont servir les intérêts de l'union et à
linverse ne vont pas affecter les
intérêts financiers de l'union
européenne
grosso modo on veut s'assurer pour le
dire clairement on veut s'assurer que
ces fonds ne seront pas versés sous
forme de pots de vin à des entreprises
qui seraient proches d'un décideur
public quels qu'ils soient
le la pologne d'ailleurs et la hongrie
ne sont pas du tout visé on s'assure
simplement de la bonne allocation de ces
fonds est pour cela que faut-il pour
cela il faut une justice indépendante et
c'est là-dessus en fait que porte cette
que cette conditionnalité constitue une
sorte de 2,2 demande aux états d'aligner
leurs systèmes judiciaires pour que la
justice de manière indépendante puisse
sanctionner d utilisation frauduleuse
des fonds qui seraient versées par la
commission européenne et par l'union
européenne olivier une réaction à ce que
j'en dis sylvie matelly on est quand
même loin des menaces d'ingérence grandi
par les anglais c'est une menace d'
ingérence vous faut être clair je veux
dire c'est c'est l'europe qui dit nous
allons décider pour vous et nous allons
nous immiscer on va avoir une
juridiction en fait plus haute que les
vôtres et nous allons nous imiter la
pologne respecte l'état de droit la
pologne elle a une constitution elle
respecte l'état de droit je vois pas en
quoi elle ne respecte pas pour l'instant
en tout cas pas moins que monsieur
macron un pas mieux pas moins bien que
monsieur macron donc on est dans quelque
chose ou on est là en train de nous dire
la justice n'est pas indépendante en
pologne mais la justice elle est aussi
indépendante qu'en france vidéo et vous
n'y a aucune
il ya évidemment aucun juge mais
indépendant les juges les juges
dépendent du ministère de la justice
dépendent du parquet qui décide ou doux
du ministre de la justice qui des six 6
il poursuit aussi poursuit pas qu'est ce
que ça veut dire c'est juste c'est juste
simplement parce que depuis un moment le
la partie on va dire progressis de
l'europe
monsieur macron en tête n'a pas envie
qu'on lui résiste n'a pas envie qu'on
fasse ce qui n'a pas décidé donc si le
l'europe décide de faire rentrer comme
madame merkel a fait un million de
migrants
il n'y a aucun souci la pologne doit
suivre non c'est des pays qui sont que
je sache encore souverain et qui n'ont
pas envie a donc qui disent non et et
pour qu'il dise non alors que c'est les
principaux comme vous l'avez dit
bénéficiaires de ce plan de relance
ça peut bien dire qu'il ya un vrai souci
parce que sinon ils le feraient pas ils
ont tout intérêt à accepter a fermé les
yeux et si c'était aussi anodins que
vous le dis ce que vous le dit à
l'instant et bien croyez moi que la
pologne et la hongrie seraient ravis
d'être les premiers à le signer vu ce
qu'ils vont toucher cinéma télé une
réaction peut être à ce que vous venez
d'entendre oui alors je crois pas qu'il
soit qu'il soit question de décider si
les polonais sont moins bons que les
français souhaitent les français se sont
d'ailleurs fait attraper à plusieurs
reprises sur l'indépendance de leur
justice et ont mené en mener les
réformes nécessaires peut-être pas
suffisante et peut-être se font sentir
rattraper dans quelques années pour ça
simplement moi je suis con tribuables
européenne
je trouve formidable qui une solidarité
qui se met en place au niveau européen
et qu'on aille aider les pays qui sont
le plus en difficulté qui subissent le
plus la crise en plus c'est pas juste
une question de solidarité c'est aussi
une question de reprise économique et
comme tous nos destins et toutes nos
économies sans oublier on n'y a tous
intérêt à ce que l'économie européenne
repartent très rapidement simplement en
tant que contribuable français et donc
européen je serai un petit peu gêné aux
entournures si j'apprenais que les
milliards qui ont été versés un certain
nombre de pays un certain nombre
d'étapes pour relancer l'économie sont
allés dans la poche de copains des
décideurs dans ces états et dans ces
pays c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose
qui est politiquement c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas soutenable et je
trouve que
union européenne est dans son rôle que
de surveiller de vérifier ce qui se
passe dans ces pays
et si les fonds qui vont être alloués
pour la relance se sont effectivement à
allouer aux citoyens aux consommateurs
aux entreprises et pas juste à des
copains des dirigeants en place
quant aux dirigeants eux mêmes qui sont
anti européen de longue date c'est bien
connu et donc ils sont dans une posture
aussi ils sont pas là pour applaudir et
dire c'est formidable et de toute façon
je pense que ils vont très rapidement
cédé sur ces points là parce qu'ils ont
besoin de cet argent et ils ont ils ont
besoin de cet argent pour relancer leur
économie
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une urgence
absolue puisque on est encore dans cette
pandémie du coc vide et qu'on lutte
encore contre l'urgence mais dans
quelques semaines voir dans quelques
mois je doute que les gouvernements
polonais ou en groix renonça à ces
montants là
alors bien évidemment il se met dans une
posture où ils veulent quand les laisse
faire ce qu'on veut mais attention le
risque existe le risque est réel que ces
fonds soient détournées pour verser des
pots-de-vin ou pour verser de l'argent à
des proches des gouvernements des pays
concernés et encore une fois c'est pas
seulement la pologne ou landry c'est en
général la clause de conditionnalité
elle s'applique à tous les pays
européens participant à ce plan de
relance alors justement on va jeter un
oeil du côté du montant des aides
allouées à chaque pays lieu devrait
verser 23 milliards de dollars à la
pologne entre 2021 et 2027 dans le cadre
donc du plan de relance on est à 6
milliards
du côté de la hongrie alors olivier les
de ces pays-là peuvent-ils se passer de
ses ailes et surtout ces pays ont-ils
les moyens de faire perdurer ce bras de
fer en définit mans où ils ont les
moyens de faire perdurer le bras de fer
pendant un petit moment ce qui concerne
la pl la pologne très probablement mais
en effet c'est ce que je vous dis ils en
ont besoin et les montants sont
conséquents et c'est bien pour ça que il
ya réel problème est que ils ont peu
disons pas envie de se faire imposer
quoi que ce soit par l'europe alors
notre invité nous dit que elle est gênée
en tant que contribuable que les
montants soient versés à des copains des
des politiques
le milliard versé à gillet à deux ça
vous gêne en tant que contribuable ou
pas du tout par l'europe pour les
ramener ici vire qui a été condamnée par
l'om s il ya quelque chose qui vous gêne
ou pas pourtant c'est l'europe
c'est là-bas rouiba donc à moi si vous
voulez j'ai plus peur de l'europe que de
la pologne aujourd'hui donc je pense que
s'il ya des conflits d'intérêts s'il y a
aujourd'hui de la corruption c'est
plutôt en europe que ça se passe dans
d'autres pays que dans les pays polonais
et hongrois
donc vous voyez enfin je veux dire il
faut quand même relativiser un tout
petit peu les choses
aujourd'hui on a essayé le les pays
comme l'allemagne et la france ont
essayé de reprendre la main sur des sur
la pologne et la hongrie parce que la
pologne et la hongrie
rue dans les brancards et sa pas
simplement depuis le plan de relance y
est rude dans les brancards depuis un
moment et est donc ça fâche
monsieur monsieur macro et madame merkel
exactement comme souvenez vous quand
monsieur salvini avait aussi rués dans
les salles et l'analyse avait fâché
sérieusement donc tout ce qui de toute
façon attaque ou remet en cause le
système mafieux entre pairs européens et
bien fâche les principaux décideurs de
l'europe c'est normal jusque là c'est
normal
et avant de poursuivre on a marqué une
courte pause et on revient dans un
instant bienvenue dans ces cas si vous
nous rejoignez au sommaire le blocage de
la hongrie face au plan de relance de
l'union européenne et pour en parler
nous sommes avec k sylvie matelly
économistes et directrice adjointe de
l'iris l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques
sylvie matelly justement qu'est ce qui
fait que ces pays-là bloc le plan de
relance maintenant pourquoi ne pas avoir
négocié ces clauses par exemple en
juillet dernier alors en juillet dernier
il ya eu tout un débat sur la
conditionnalité et je me permets de
préciser parce que c'est très important
dans l'analyse je me permets de préciser
que cette clause de confidentialité elle
a été imposée par ce qu'on appelait les
pays frugaux à l'époque donc les
pays-bas les danois est pas du tout la
france ou l'allemagne en réalité qui
aurait préféré laisser un petit peu sous
le tapis pour éviter de se fâcher avec
les autres d'autres pays dont une taxe
et avait bien tandis qu'au soleil
ouanary c'était une condition celle
causée par an dans ces pays là c'est une
condition sine qua none pour tous les
pays mais encore une fois quand le plan
de relance a été négocié au mois de
juillet la conditionnalité né n'était
pas prévu initialement dans ce plan de
relance est ce sens qu'on a appelé les
pays frugaux qui bloquaient ce plan de
relance à l'été donc le les pays bas le
danemark l'autriche qui ont exigé qu'on
impose une clause de conditionnalité
encore une fois dans une logique de pays
frugaux c'est à dire s'il était frugaux
s'ils ne souhaitaient pas ce plan de
relance c'est qu'ils avaient peur que
l'on distribue de l'argent à des pays
qui allait de là
jean européen donc payé par le
contribuable européen donc par des
contribuables de leurs des citoyens de
leur propre pays
de l'argent qui allait être dépensés à
des fins qu'il ne qu'il n'estimait pas
souhaitable qu'ils allaient être
gaspillés par départ les pays
club med c'est comme ça qu'ils le
voyaient voir qui allait qui allait
passer dans des canaux de corruption
divers et variés donc ce sont vraiment
ces pays et c'est pas du tout la france
l allemagne la france et l'allemagne
s'en sort est bien passé parce que ça va
être simplifié la tâche
alors pour répondre à votre question
pourquoi il bloque aujourd'hui ils n'ont
pas bloqué cet été bien je pense que
parce que cet été ils n'ont pas vu venir
après quatre jours de négociations ils
n'ont pas vu venir cette clause de
conditionnalité ils s'en sont rendu
compte en fait ils s'en sont pas rendu
compte au moins novembre mais tant qu'on
était en fait dans la négociation d'un
traité
il était pour ce plan de relance donc
ils ont signé partir du moment où leur
demande de rendre des comptes pour
recevoir l'argent qu'ils vont toucher
les 7 et les 23 milliards dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure
là il commence à dire ah ben non moi je
veux l'argent mais je veux pas rendre
des comptes
donc c'est c'est pour ça que ça arrive
maintenant puisque c'est maintenant
qu'on est vraiment en train de mettre de
l'huile dans les rouages dans la machine
pour pour lancer ce plan de relance
l'idée c'était de donner de distribuer
l'argent très rapidement enfin avant la
fin de l'année ou au début de l'année
prochaine donc c'est à ce moment là
qu'on demande comme quand vous allez à
la bande négocié un crédit on vous
demande un certain nombre de deux hommes
de documents de respecter un certain
nombre de critères et c'est une fois
qu'on leur demande de respecter ces
critères que il se met en bouteille et
encore une fois je veux bien précisé que
la conditionnalité elle s'applique à
tous les pays et elle ne porte que sur
la question la justice qui doit être
indépendante et en capacité de vérifier
que l'argent est allouée à au poste qui
ont été négociées au niveau de l'europe
je le dis très clairement la france ne
renoncera à ni à la relance ni à ses
valeurs nous regarderons en dernier
ressort comment avancer sans les pays
qui bloquent ce sont là les mots de
clément bonne secrétaire d'état chargé
des affaires européennes devant
les sénateurs le 18 novembre dernier
olivier est ce qu'il est possible de
contourner ces veto et par exemple de
ratifier ce plan à 25
quand vous êtes dans un système anti
démocratiques comme l'europe oui tout
est possible ça fait ça fait depuis la
crise de 2008 qu'on s'assoit allègrement
sur tous les traités donc vous savez un
de plus
1 - c'est pas bien gravissime et donc on
vous trouvera est un prétexte
ils trouveront un prétexte pour faire
passer leurs leur plan de relance le
plan de relance d'ailleurs dont moi en
tant que contribuable français je
m'inquiète lourdement puisque je vous
rappelle que dans ce plan de relance il
est prévu qu'on touche 40 milliards mais
qu'on paye 100 milliards ça fait moins
que je sache et donc nous allons payer
60 milliards de notre poche à l'europe
et donc si vous voulez moi je me réjouis
que ce plan soit bloquée et s'il pouvait
même être annulé j'en serais ravi si
l'idée matelly à une réaction
alors je pense que déjà une alternative
pour les polonais et les hongrois
puisqu'il s'oppose à la conditionnalité
ce plan de relance a aurait été d'y
renoncer et de dire au fond nous tant
pis on y participe raconte touchera pas
l'argent il n'a jamais été question de
ça deuxièmement ce plan de relance je me
permets de rappeler qu' il est de 750
milliards et que sur ses 750 milliards
il ya 500 milliards
voire plus d'ailleurs il était question
de l'intégralité une bonne partie de ce
plan de relance qui va être financé par
un an par des emprunts auprès de la
banque centrale européenne donc pour
l'instant à priori ça ne coûtera pas aux
états la répartition qui est affiché sur
la responsabilité des sommes versées
c'est une répartition qui est pour
l'instant indicative et on ne sait pas
on ne sait pas ce qui va ce qui va ce
qui va naître dans les années qui
viennent en tout cas la grande nouveauté
de ce plan de relance c'est que il ya la
possibilité pour la commission
européenne de s'endetter auprès de la
bce donc avec une dette dans des
conditions qui sont enfermés définitive
n'aura pas de spread de taux
d'augmentation des taux d'intérêt il y
aura pas de surenchérissement du coût de
cette dette
et puis avec des possibilités de
rembourser sur des périodes extrêmement
longues comme ça a été comme ça a été
notée donc ça c'est important de le
rappeler parce que ça donne quand même
une un souffle un souffle de das et long
terme aux économies européennes pour
pouvoir se relancer pour pouvoir
investir dans leurs économies
je crois que l'absence de plan de
relance se conduire est quand même à
deux des normes issime difficultés de la
part des états qui n'ont probablement
pas les moyens de soutenir
l'augmentation de dette nationale que
l'absence de ce plat ce plan
impliquerait c'est d'ailleurs bien pour
ça que la plupart des pays européens s'y
sont ralliés cet été y compris les pays
des plus frugaux comprenant que le
risque les risques économiques étaient
bien plus important économiques et
financiers bien plus importants avec des
plans nationaux que si on prévoyait un
plan de relance européen eelv et une
dernière réaction avant de refermer ce
chapitre la dette ans et repousser le
problème donc vous ne vous n'avez vous
avez une dette qui augmente alors après
vous pouvez la halle à mutualiser et
puis dire où on verra la répartition
plus tard mais ça n'empêche que la
répartition il y aura à un moment et que
cette répartition tombera évidemment sur
avec la même clé de répartition très
probablement que le poids dans la bce et
donc la france aura sa partie des dettes
et est malheureusement vu le
l'idée que peuvent avoir certains
politiques de ce qu'est un
investissement figurez vous qu'on ne
reverra jamais l'esu donc ça sera de
l'impôt pour les générations futures
comme d'habitude c'est pas j'invente
rien
je vois que ça vous fait rire mais
malheureusement ça c'est quand même une
réalité et ça sera au final le
contribuable européen donc vous et moi
qui paieront la note sylvie matelly
juste rapidement en animant ajouté
peut-être oui pour l'instant c'est
difficile de dire ce que deviendra cette
dette
il est d'ailleurs question même de dette
perpétuelle en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que la dette ça se
monétise aussi et que à l'heure actuelle
on voit les dettes s'accroître vous
l'avez très bien dit depuis depuis des
années des décennies et en les
remboursant les rembourse pas ce qui est
dramatique d'ailleurs parce qu'on est
dans une spirale de la dette qui peut
qui peut inquiéter
donc l'avenir nous le dira mais il n'est
pas il n'est pas certain que in fine et
ce soit au contribuable de financer
cessé d'être là en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que valent les difficultés
économiques elles sont elles sont elles
sont là elles sont là et elles vont se
poursuivre dans les mois à venir et
qu'il faut bien réagir et soutenir tous
les toutes les entreprises qui souffrent
aujourd'hui de cette énorme crise
économique
merci beaucoup si on ne les avait pas
fermé vous vous verriez que ça irait
mais beaucoup mieux merci merci beaucoup
sylvie matelly d'avoir été parmi nous
dans cette émission je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste et directrice adjointe
de l'iris institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques au iv
nous on continue fille avec les
questions cash
et on commence tout de suite avec la
question de roger bécaud vide ou pas
est-ce que ce n'est finalement pas la
fiscalité qui va jouer sur
l'attractivité de la france dans les
mois à venir
roger avez-vous des enseignements sur la
fiscalité dans les mois à venir
non il est évident que de toute façon
avec tout ce qu'on fait les états en
termes de plan de soutien de plan de
relance avec un endettement qui est
juste gigantesque
il va bien falloir le payer et donc je
voulais toujours dit ici le la dette
c'est de l'impôt futur donc évidemment
la fiscalité ne va pas évoluer dans le
bon sens dans les mois et dans les
années à venir donc sur ce plan là
l'attractivité de la france me paraît
pas très forte
en plus vous avez d'autres éléments
qu'il faut prendre en compte vous avez
je suppose que vous avez tous des des
enfants ou des étudiants autour de vous
et à quoi rêvent aujourd'hui un étudiant
français allait faire ses études
ailleurs
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
vous avez un certain nombre de cerveaux
qui s'en vont faire leurs études
ailleurs et qui s'en vont travailler
ailleurs donc ça veut dire que ça va
être de moins en moins intéressant de
venir en france parce que les
compétences vous les avez perdu vous les
avez perdu dans l'artisanat vous les
avez perdus dans l'industrie puisqu'on a
d industrialiser la france depuis
plusieurs années
donc vous avez perdu ccc manière de
faire vous avez perdu quelques cerveaux
qui sont partis et dans des pays voisins
et donc que je pense que la france est
de moins en moins attractive alors la
seule chose qui pouvait faire quelle
qu'elle soit attractive
c'était la fiscalité c'était le fait de
donner des franchises des gens qui
s'installent et sauf qu'on voit très
bien que à la fin de leur franchise
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils partent on
passe à la question de vie 99 c'est bien
votre compte et sur les entreprises
étrangères mais au final les deux
millions d'emplois qu'elle nous
fournissent on ne pourrait pas les avoir
aussi en favorisant mieux
les entreprises françaises moins
d'impôts des réductions de charges
patronales ou un droit du travail plus
flexible sur l'énoncé de tout ce qu'il
faudrait faire je ne sais pas ce qu'est
ce que ce que je pense c'est que on a
tous fait déjà pour que les entreprises
françaises partent et c'était un
ensemble de choses n'y avait pas
simplement la fiscalité mais il y avait
un ensemble de choses qui ont fait que
beaucoup d'entreprises et dont les
entreprises industrielles sont partis à
l'étranger parce qu'il y avait des coûts
- moins important parce qu'il y avait
une main d'oeuvre qui travaillaient plus
qui et c'est donc ils sont partis
maintenant si vous ne changez pas les
conditions qu'il est qui les ont fait
partir vous risquez pas de les revoir
revenir
a priori donc c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
des conditions exceptionnelles à des
gens qui en profité pour venir
s'installer chez nous mais on a créé un
on n'a absolument pas créer les
conditions pour que les entreprises
françaises qui était parti revienne et
qu'on réindustrialiser la france parce
que aussi je vous ai dit on l'a fait
depuis tellement longtemps depuis
tellement longtemps on a des entreprises
qui sont partis que on a perdu le
savoir-faire bien bien souvent dans
plusieurs métiers dont qu'on ne
retrouvera pas comme ça merci beaucoup
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
d'adressé à toutes vos questions à
olivier sur les réseaux sociaux ou en
commentaire des vidéos on se retrouve à
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro en attendant vous pouvez
retrouver toutes nos précédentes
émissions sur notre site internet à
l'adresse rt france pointe tv olivier
c'est à vous pour le mot de la fin en
matière d'europe
aucun pays n'est trop petit pour tout
bloquer